>>Rachel: Hello everyone.
How are you?
Alright.
Yeah, I saw a fist pump out there.
Awesome.
Well welcome everybody and thank you so much
for coming to join today's at Google Authors
Talk.
Today we are in for a very special treat.
We have Ariane de Bonvoisin, who has joined
us from New York, and she's gonna talk about
her latest book, it's called The First 30
Days and like I mentioned, they're for sale
in the back for the bargain price of $5.00.
Thank you Google.
And what she's gonna cover in the book is
really addressing the question, is there a
way to make change easier?
I'm sure we're all pondering that and have
pondered that, whether your change or things
that are going on happen to be about career,
relationships, health, finance, pretty much
any big life issue.
So Ariane is gonna talk about her nine principles
of change and how that can help anyone out
in any change that they're going through.
Ariane's written many books and in her past,
previous career before, before being an author,
she actually was in management consulting,
so she comes from a good business background
and has applied a lot of that to her writing.
She's also ventured into other areas lately,
like developing iphone apps, so you may even
know that she's coming out with an app called
Mindful365 and you may even be beta testing
that, if anyone is doing that Ariane is trying
to apply some of these principles into a mobile
app, which is awesome.
So if you're interested in that you can also
let her know at the end.
And, and what else?
Ariane is a great avid traveler, she's been
to 60 countries and part of that was a two-year
hiatus that she took and recently returned
from and had a incredible journey which actually,
little, little spoiler alert here, we're actually
gonna be talking about some of her travel
later today where she appears in a documentary
film about traveling the Himalayas on a motorcycle,
and it's called The Highest Pass.
So lots going on today with Ariane.
We're very excited to have her.
Please welcome Ariane de Bonvoisin.
[applause]
>>Ariane: Rachel, thank you.
She does those big acknowledgments.
I know that she's brought a lot of amazing
people here.
And she's hosting me and she, she goes way
and beyond just taking care of authors and
other people, so really thank you, it's a,
it's a blessing.
So we have probably I think about an hour
together.
What I was gonna do is just tell you a little
bit about my story.
Why I'm here and what I'm doing with my life
these days, which is very different, it's
been a big change to what I used to be doing,
and then I'm gonna take you through the nine
principles of change as quick as I can.
I usually take like three hours or a whole
day to do them, so I'm gonna like speed through
them and then I'm gonna stick around and take
as many questions as you guys have time for.
And then as I said the film is gonna be screening
I think at 3:30 in the same room.
So if you guys can take an entire day off
work, I'll be [audience laughter] totally
here for you.
So with that said you can hear obviously I
have an accent.
It's usually the first question I get asked.
I usually ask people do they any sense of
sort of where I'm from or what the accent
is?
Anyone wants to guess?
There's a free book in the back for the guess.
No?
Yes.
>>male #1: New Zealand.
>>Ariane: New Zealand.
Not.
Anyway I'll make it quick.
I was born in the U.S., believe it or not,
so I'm actually American by birth.
I have a French mother and a Belgian father
and I grew up in six different countries,
so I don't really know where my accent's from.
And depending on who I'm with I sort of the
accent sort of tends to change, but I grew
up in the U.S., I grew up in Paris, in Brussels,
London, Hong Kong and also in China.
So I think without knowing it my parents were
sort of getting me ready for this lifetime
career of change, although I just didn't know
it at the time.
But you get exposed to very different schools
and religious environments and cultures and
food and you name it, you sort of get given
this sort of big trip into change.
And even despite all the change that I've
been given what happened was that I tended
to do what I would consider the safe route.
So I went to college, I went to the London
School of Economics, graduated first in my
class, did what I thought was expected of
me.
So I had this sort of big should program on
I should study hard.
I should go to college.
I should go to certain companies.
So the next should was to go into management
consulting.
I studied economics and it felt like it was
just the right next thing to do.
So I joined The Boston Consulting Group and
did a couple years with them.
They sent me all around the world, which made
that experience a little bit easier for me.
But I always kind of had an inkling that something
wasn't quite right.
I kind of knew that it wasn't really what
I was here to be doing.
I sort of shut that voice down for a little
while longer, then I came out here and I went
to business school.
So I went to Stanford and you know that was
sort of an amazing experience, but I kept
on sort of saying you know what should I do
with my life?
That was sort of the big lingering question
in the background.
And I traipsed off to New York City after
that and I spent ten years in the media world.
And I worked at Bertelsmann, I worked at Sony,
I worked at Time/Warner.
And as you can tell I was jumping around a
lot and I kept on trying to sort of figure
out what is, what is actually right, what,
what am I meant to be doing with my life?
And I landed at Time/Warner at the age of
28/29 in charge of a $500 million venture
capital fund.
And I was managing director of this fund and
I was you know supposedly had climbed this
very high ladder, but I had the sense that
it was the wrong ladder and it was definitely
leaning up against the wrong wall.
And even though I had this semblance of a
very perfect sort of external life, what started
happening was that inner microphone that you
all have started going off pretty loudly.
And the inner microphone sounds like this,
"Ariane, you're in the wrong job."
That was the first inner microphone.
The second inner microphone was, "Ariane,
you're sleeping with the wrong guy."
[audience laughter] That was the second one.
And I thought, how is it possible that I've
set up this perfect life and none of it's
right and all of it needs to now change.
So I was about 30/31 and it's a long story,
but I eventually had the courage to leave
that job.
And I actually had no idea what was gonna
come next.
I was sort of in that void and in between
careers and couldn't quite see what, what
was coming.
And so what I did was I started getting really
honest with myself.
What was the number one thing that was missing
for me?
And it was the sense that I wasn't really
making a difference.
I wasn't really adding value, I wasn't really
contributing.
And it's interesting.
If you look at like all the research now going
on in the U.S., the number one reason people
are unhappy at work and people in general
have this sense of slight depression, you
know Gallup Poll did a poll recently where
more than two-thirds of employees are unhappy
in their work.
And the number one reason is because people
don't feel that they're actually adding value.
So I was feeling that big time.
And so I did what I knew best, which is I
went off and I went traveling.
And I started asking myself very different
questions.
So instead of creating this externally perfect
life, I sort of turned my entire focus inwards
and I started asking very internal questions.
What's worth doing with this life?
What does Ariane want to do?
Not my parents, not what was expected of me,
not, not sort of all this external conditioning,
what I call the tribe.
Where the tribe has sort of told you what
is expected of you.
And it was while I was traveling I sort of
had this one question to life.
Show me the way.
Show me what's next.
Show me what I'm meant to be doing.
And I sort of walked around a few different
countries with sort of antenna on my head.
And I was just looking for signs and synchronicities
and things that could give me a clue.
And what I realized was that every single
person I was meeting was in one of three categories
and all of you are in this as well.
They were either going through some sort of
a change.
They were either thinking about making a change,
but had some sort of excuse or something going
on in the way.
Or they were helping someone with a change.
So it was a spouse or a friend or a partner
or a child or a colleague.
And then I found out later through I was giving
a speech somewhere else and someone said,
no, there's a fourth category.
And I was like, bring it on.
And the fourth category, which some of us
are all guilty of, is we're waiting for someone
else to change, not us.
[audience laughter] We're waiting for someone
else to change, it has nothing to do with
us.
But it was interesting that this change thing
was all around me.
And I met people who were, had gotten divorced.
And I met people who had just you know lost
a parent.
And I met people who had just found out their
child was autistic.
And I met people who were getting through
depression.
And I met people who had just lost their job.
But it was like this change thing was all
around me and I thought, isn't it interesting
that change is the number one guarantee in
life.
JFK said it's the law of life, and yet no
one knows how to go through it.
And I thought there must be ways to make change
easier.
Like we, we're all going through it.
I personally believe it's the most important
life skill to get good at.
As parents we protect our kids from change.
We definitely do not throw them into change.
The less change, the more stable.
The more calm the more you think you're doing
your kids a favor, which is not the case.
And as adults we walk into the world and we're
thrown with so much change and we actually
don't have the skills to sort of navigate
it.
So what I sort of started thinking was what
happens if I interviewed people and just sort
of started listening to why is it that you're
good at change and someone else has a really
hard time?
Why is it that some of you are thinking about
a change and others of you have actually gone
on and done that?
And it was fascinating to me that some of
us were naturally good at change and others
weren't.
Were men better at change than women?
So it sort of, it sort of descended on me
it's like just go research this.
It wasn't sort of, this is your next job or
this is what you're gonna be meant to be doing
with your life.
And so I started interviewing people and I
found, in effect, that there were ways to
make change easier.
So what I wanted to do is, I'm gonna take
you through these nine principles.
What I did eventually was I did write a book
about it, right over here, The First 30 Days.
I called it The First 30 Days because I wanted
people to get a sense that it just it takes
more than just sort of the action plan or
the three things to do or you know here is
how you start a business, here is how you
leave a job you don't like.
There's actually sort of emotions that you
need to actually go through when you go through
change.
I started a website as well that goes with
it first30days.com.
But what I wanted to say before I take you
through the nine principles, three things.
Most of us when we think about change we think
about external changes.
When we're gonna meet the soul mate.
When we're gonna get married.
When we're gonna have kids.
When we're gonna have the big promotion.
The most effective and the most important
changes you will ever make in your life are
internal changes.
Changes about how you see yourself.
Changes about your identity.
Changes about who you decide to forgive.
Changes about who you decide to get honest
with.
Internal changes, the identity of who you
are and who you see yourself to be, those
are the changes that change everything.
It's not when the external changes happen.
You're gonna see that through the nine principles
that came out very, very strongly.
The second thing is change is all about getting
comfortable with the unknown.
It's not about clinging to here's how it's
gonna be or here's how someone else's experience
was and that's what it's gonna be.
It's all about getting comfortable with that
void of actually not knowing how it's gonna
be.
And the third thing is the very best of who
you are comes out during times of change.
It does not come out when everything is really
certain and perfect.
The very, your core essence is actually to
go through changes.
When you're comfortable, that's when life
feels quite dull.
When you're actually going through things,
that's when like there's life force, there's
juice that's actually coming through you.
So the invitation is to sort of you know give
you a sense of well, where are you on the
change spectrum?
So to do that I'm just gonna throw out a few
questions whether you wanna ask them in your
head or write them down is sort of up to you,
but, and I do this with all the groups I talk
to.
The first question is, naturally, do you think
you are good at change?
Yes or no?
What comes up?
Are you, are you a change optimist?
Do you move towards change or you're like
I'm so not a change person?
If things never change I'd be much happier
the way it is.
Second question, do you feel you are better
at making changes or at facing changes that
come your way?
Are you one that naturally goes after a new
change or are you actually really good when
life just goes handle it, deal with it?
Because it's two very different types of people.
You know most people can kind of go I'm really
good at change and they're really good in
the crisis.
But if you actually asked them what are changes
they'd love to make, they don't go close to
them.
That's the second question.
Third question, just to give you a sense of
what I call your change history.
You know, the core of who you are, are all
the changes you've ever made, been through,
faced, witnessed other people going through.
That's it.
You know you, you are a walking combination
of all the changes you've had the courage
to make and get through.
What is the very best change you've ever made?
It could have been to get married.
It could have been to finally get divorced.
It could have been to have children.
It could have been to come and work here.
It could have been to finally listen to that
inner microphone and go, you know what, I
hate this job, it's killing my soul, I can't
do this anymore.
It could have been to quit smoking.
It could have been to lose weight.
It could have been to take care of an elderly
parent.
What's the very best change, when you've,
you see the consequences of what happened?
It might have been super hard at the time,
but what was the best change?
Next one, you can guess which one's coming
now.
What is the hardest change you've ever been
through?
Hardest change you've ever been through?
Seeing a parent be depressed.
Losing a loved one.
Something going on with a child.
Being fired.
You know there's so many, you know being wrongly
accused about something.
The hardest change you've ever been through?
And then the final question is what is a change
that you, you've been thinking about making?
You'd love to make?
There, there's something where you'd like
you know I'd love to take time off.
I'd love to start my own business.
I'd love to ask someone to marry me.
I'd love to have a child.
And then ask yourself what is, what's in the
way of you making that change?
Because having interviewed maybe a couple
of thousand people by now about change, there's
only a certain amount of excuses that I've
heard of.
So I'm gonna run a few of them through and
if you guys have new excuses you can throw
them at me.
Excuses why people don't make changes.
One, I don't have time.
Another one I hear all the time is, it's gonna
cost money.
Another one is I'm too old.
On the flip side, I'm too young.
Another one which I hear a lot is, it's not
my nature, I'm not the sort of guy that does
this or I'm not the sort of girl that does
this.
That's the identity change, right?
The hardest change you'll ever make is an
identity change of how you see yourself.
You go from being a business person, myself,
to being more of a creative person.
That's an incredibly difficult change to eventually
make.
But it's not my nature.
Another one is, someone's gonna disapprove.
Very big excuse.
Someone's gonna be upset with me.
Someone's gonna be disappointed.
Someone's gonna think I'm crazy.
It could be a parent.
It could be a partner.
But someone is really gonna get in the way
and sort of go, no, you can't do that, 'cause
it's gonna threaten them as well.
But someone's gonna disapprove.
Another one that I, I hear a lot is that you
know it's just not worth it.
I'm comfortable.
I'm in a safe place.
I'm in a safe environment.
I'm in a safe job.
I'm in a safe marriage.
There's this safety thing that again people
are not really willing.
So whatever the excuse is for you, just keep
it in mind.
You know a lot of this is just bringing out
of your blind spot things that are actually
running the change show that you've probably
never really considered.
So having said that I'm gonna just jump in
and, and dive right into these nine principles.
So these came from as I said about 2,000 interviews,
people all around the world, every country
I would go to, I'd sit next to someone on
a plane or I'd sit, you know, and actually
have a proper formal interview and tape them.
And I would ask them, you know, a selection
of questions and just try and elicit what
made change easier.
So what you're gonna hear in these nine principles
is some of them are incredibly obvious.
Some of them are very basic and very simple.
And it is always the simple things that we
don't do.
We're much better doing complicated things.
We're really not very good at doing the obvious,
simple things.
So as you hear some of these, just ask yourself,
is this one of the principles I'm actually
pretty good at or should I take a note and
actually work a little bit?
Some of them you're gonna be already great
at.
So the first principle of change, people who
successfully navigate change have positive
beliefs.
That's it.
If I had to build a house in front of you
here and I had to lay the bricks of the foundation
of how and why people go through change, your
beliefs are the number one thing that are
gonna either make this easier or more difficult.
What do I mean about beliefs?
Beliefs about three different things.
Beliefs about yourself, beliefs about life,
and beliefs about the specific change that
you're either making or going to be facing.
Let's throw out beliefs about yourself.
Most of us have terrible beliefs about ourselves.
Most of all, most of us are in poor me.
Or you know you're living small.
Or you're playing the victim.
Or you're blaming someone else.
The average person disapproves of themselves
between 50 and 65 times a day.
A day.
That's how bad the mental dialog is, you know?
So just being aware of what are the worst
things that I keep telling myself?
Because you're not even aware of them.
I usually invite people to do what I call
a 24-hour disapproval challenge, which is
for the next 24 hours, just catch yourself
every time you disapprove.
What you said, what you did, what you ate,
what you didn't eat, what you should have
said in a meeting, what you sent as an e-mail,
what you wore, what, whatever it is.
How long you slept.
The wrong route that you choose in traffic.
What, just be aware of the level of mental
chatter that is going on.
But the beliefs that you have about yourself,
you're either giving yourself a green light
to walk or you're actually consistently holding
yourself back.
But the disapproval is probably one of the
biggest fundamental stumbling blocks when
people are going through change.
Beliefs about life.
This is one of the juiciest ones that I really
like.
When I was interviewing people, I could always
notice that when people where talking about
change, somehow they believed that life was
on their side.
So Einstein said it much better than I did,
the most important decision you'll ever make
in your life is to decide whether you live
in a friendly universe or an unfriendly universe.
That's it.
The most important decision you'll ever make
in your life, is life on your side, is life
against you?
Are you lucky, are you unlucky?
Is life pissing you off, one more obstacle,
one more challenge?
Or is life actually giving you challenges
because it's moving you in the right direction?
That is it.
Whichever way you go you will have two very
different lives.
You know people who have a very optimistic
view of even though life tragedies, really
tough stuff has happened, positive things
have sort of come on from those people.
I don't know which one you guys are.
But if there's one thing to look at, is, is
life your partner, is life against you?
Because life will be very different.
And then the third one is looking at well
what's the specific change that's actually
happening for you?
You know you have beliefs about changing jobs.
You have beliefs about getting divorced.
You have beliefs about losing weight.
Actually looking at where are those beliefs
from?
Who's told you those things?
You need to consciously choose what it is
that those beliefs are about.
The one thing that you'll see in, in, in this
first principle is that when people are good
at change, they are very committed to one
thing, which is they're committed to finding
inside what the lesson is when they're going
through change.
External change happens.
What do we do?
We try and run and fix the outside.
It's a very external thing.
It's never about what to do on the outside.
It's about checking in what's going on on
the inside.
What's my lesson here?
Why is this happening?
How am I self responsible?
Which is not something we like looking at.
It's always, you know, the energy goes out.
People who are gonna change are very inwardly
focused.
It's a very sort of what I call a deep looking
experiment.
If you're going through a change right now
or you're looking at making a change, make
it from the inside out.
It's not about figuring out how to move the
pieces on the outside.
Ok.
Principle number two.
Another one of my favorites.
Principle number two is what I call the change
guarantee.
The change guarantee states this: From this
situation, from this change, something good
will come.
That's it.
I have it written all over my office.
I've given it to all our employees.
I have it in my car.
I have it in my bathroom so that when that
change happens, when the e-mail comes in and
something starts changing, when the phone
call comes in, when the person comes in and
says something to you and you go into your
normal change emotions, which we're gonna
talk about, if the first thing you can go
to is, from this change something good will
come, you start moving in that direction of
what the blessing is.
If you go into, you know, bad things are happening,
this is really challenging, you're actually
gonna get more of that.
I teach this principle to kids and somehow
adults really complicate this.
Kids get this immediately.
Something's changing and they can immediately
go to well something not necessarily better
but something good is gonna come from this.
Why is change so hard?
Because we cling to our plans.
We are obsessed with our plans.
We're addicted, if you have one addiction,
it's to the way you think your life needs
to be going.
I'm gonna be married by this age, I'm gonna
have this job and this money and this house
and life goes, uh-uh, and then we all go into
suffering.
It's not about life moving the pieces, it's
about clinging and being so attached to life
going in the my way direction.
If you can just sort of relax into life and
just go you know what, life maybe has my best
interest at heart.
Life somehow has always guided me in the right
way.
But unloosening from the gripping and the
clinging, that's the thing that makes you
suffer through change.
It's not actually the change itself.
The change guarantee, you know, when, when
we go through change the first question we
go to is why?
Why did this happen?
Why did this happen to me?
You know, why do I now need to have the courage
to do this?
The question is never about why.
The question is always about how to be.
How to be.
How, what in me needs to shift?
What in me needs to change?
Not external changes.
Change guarantee.
If you can write it down, as I said you know
you get what you focus on.
So the more focused you are on actually finding
the positive, the more your mind is actually
gonna go looking for that.
You move into that direction.
Something good will come.
Change guarantee.
Third principle.
Third principle is what I've affectionately
called the change muscle.
People who are good at change are, they have
the sense that no matter what, they're strong,
they're resilient, they're capable, they can
get through anything, despite what they've
been told.
Despite what their parents told them.
Despite what society tells them.
Despite what people tell them they should
be doing at their particular age or in a particular
way.
There's this sense of, you know what, I know
that I'm gonna get through it, no matter what
it is that life throws my way.
And I can tell you every single one of you
in this room has gone through dozens and dozens
of life changes.
Here's the difference.
Most of you have never acknowledged yourself
for any of them.
Because when you were in them, you were so
busy trying to get through them that you never
sort of looked back and kind of go, hey, I'm
the girl that changed jobs.
You know?
Good old me.
Or hey, I'm the girl that lost a ton of weight.
Or I'm the guy that finally had the courage
to get divorced and go be with the woman that
I love.
Whatever it is.
But you have never acknowledged yourself for
all the changes you've already made.
But your body has the sense of knowing how
to change.
Your body has a sense of knowing already how
So even though the change you're thinking
about making or the change that might be in
front of you now looks like a new change,
the body goes, oh a new change, new change,
I've no idea what to do with this new change,
and that's not true.
You have a tool box already in place of how
to go through change.
If you could, you know, when I have more time
with people, I take people through what I
call their change resume, which is much more
effective and important than your professional
resume that we spend our whole life putting
together.
Your change resume are all the changes you've
made, all the changes life has thrown at you,
all the changes you've had to help other people
with and there are ways that you get through
change.
They're different for every one of you.
Most of you have a rock solid belief that
helps you no matter what go through change.
And knowing what that is is super valuable.
So it could be this too shall pass, it's just
if I give this enough time, time heals all
things.
Or I know someone can help me with this change.
Or you pray more.
You know a lot of people go to their spiritual
path when they're going through a life change.
But there is a core belief that you go through
no matter what when you're going through a
life change.
Bring that out of your blind spot.
Think about the difficult changes you've made
in the past and what is actually the things
that you took with you?
Because getting in touch with what is, what
activates your change muscle.
But we, we play so small.
We keep thinking we're not as strong, not
as powerful, not as effective.
We, you know we shrink at the first sight
of fear.
But just getting a sense like the people I
interviewed.
I interviewed people who had gone through
real traumatic things in Africa and you name
it.
And there was this sense of not education,
not money, not what their parents had told
them, there was this core fundamental inner
strength that just radiated out of them and
we're all born with it.
And it's not a, it's not a matter of like
going to find it.
It's a matter of uncovering what's blocking
it.
Right?
We've all been given it.
It's just the light that needs to sort of
come though what is in the way, what's in
the way?
Maybe it's a belief.
Maybe it's a wound or a past change that you
still sort of are trying to get through.
But just realizing you know that the level
of your change muscle, your body is born to
change.
Your body is on your side when you go through
Your body is changing every second of every
day.
It has to change, right, to keep, to survive.
Principle number four.
Gotta have a swig of water.
Principle number four is a juicy one, very
juicy.
It's what I call your change demons.
Your change demons are all the emotions that
are guaranteed to show up when you are going
through a life change.
So they're gonna walk themselves in the door
and if I tell you what they are you can be
a little bit more prepared when they sort
of walk in for the party.
What I would invite you to do is invite them
in, but don't feed them, and do not entertain
them, and do not welcome their friends in
even more, because when we feel one emotion
as human beings we tend to stack three more.
Like we're really good stackers.
Oh, I'm feeling a bit anxious.
Oh, and I'm gonna feel, you know, three more
negative things on top of that.
Somehow we do that as human beings.
Here's what I've found before I tell you what
these change demons were, which is the most
core important message of this principle.
People who are good at change are very emotional.
They are not practical.
They don't go in their to do list.
And here are the three ways to get divorced.
They feel their emotions much more deeply
than people who don't get through the change.
People who eat the emotions away, or work
the emotions away or TV or Facebook the emotions
away.
People who are good at change are much more
emotional.
So if you are emotional, you actually can
give yourself a gold star right now.
For once it's actually not a bad thing.
People who are good at change have a humanity
about them.
They allow themselves to be human.
They allow themselves to sort of go, you know
what, I didn't get the manual on how to deal
with you know my child being sick.
I didn't get the manual on how to deal with
my mother being depressed.
But there is a permission to be human.
If you are helping anyone going through a
change, this is probably the most important
principle.
Allow people to feel their emotions.
Don't change them.
Don't offer them drinks.
Just allow, be a refuge for people who are
going through change.
That was very interesting, because my sense
when I was looking for the principles was
ok there's things that people are doing that
are making them better at change.
And it wasn’t, there are things that people
are feeling that make them much better at
change.
They're feeling the fear.
Because eventually every emotion you feel
is actually gonna leave the body.
If you don't want to feel it, guess what,
it's kind of there all the time.
If you wake up in the morning, you feel one
of these emotions and you eat it away, I guarantee
you at 4:00 you're still eating it away.
I always ask this question, because it's interesting
to find out, there is an emotion in every
one of us that we do everything to avoid having
to feel.
Everything.
And we think we're not feeling it.
And the reality is that is the emotion that
is ruling your life.
It's the emotion that's constantly going on.
Why you do what you do.
Who you date.
What you eat.
Where you work is constantly being decided
by this one emotion you don't wanna feel.
Humiliation, embarrassment, not getting it
right, not getting not being perfect.
Whatever it is for you, but there's one emotion
that is holding you back in every area of
your life.
It's actually not allowing you to move forward
in any way, so get in touch with what is,
what's the one thing that I think I've kinda
got under control.
And the way to do it is to actually just allow
it up.
Speak to it.
What's the message?
Why is it actually here?
So you've been super patient, so here are
the six change demons in no particular order.
These can sort of show up in different ways
for different people and you know there is
a lot of pages in the book about particular
change demons.
The first one is obviously fear.
Fear of the unknown.
Fear of the change being permanent.
Big one.
Fear of taking it personally.
I'm responsible for this change.
This happened to me.
This change says something negative about
me.
But fear, there's so many different fears
that can sort of get involved.
For every change demon, what I did with people
is I said ok, so you're in the fear, what
actually moved you through the fear?
So there was what I called this antidote that
had to be bigger than the fear which eventually
they would go to.
The antidote to fear is faith.
Faith in yourself.
Faith in your change muscle.
Faith in someone else being able to help you.
Faith in time.
Faith in something greater.
But there's this level of what can be bigger
than the fear?
I'm still gonna allow the fear to show up,
but what's gonna be bigger than the fear?
The next change demon was doubt.
Closely related friend or twin, but the next
change demon was doubt.
Doubt of what's gonna happen now.
Doubt around money.
Doubt around ever finding another lover.
Doubt around you know when to have children.
Doubt, whatever it was.
Doubt around getting better and healing.
I interviewed a lot of people who had health
diagnoses.
The antidote to doubt is always surrender.
Because trying to make plans and certainty
with your mind is exhausting.
It's exhausting.
And it's never gonna work out the way your
perfectly beautiful mind thinks it's gonna
work out.
It's tiring.
The mind chatter of planning and strategizing
and how's it gonna be and how's it gonna work?
If you can just let go and kind of go again,
life's gonna work this out.
I'm gonna take action, but I'm gonna take
action with a still mind, not a really, really
busy hectic mind.
That's when people get through change.
It's not that you're stuck in paralysis and
just going surrender, you know, life can kind
of do it all for me.
You're still taking action, but from a still
surrendered place.
You're taking it from a humble place.
I actually don't know how it's gonna turn
out.
You know actually being able to own it and
sort of go actually I don't know.
It's a very powerful statement.
Much more so than you know most of us educated
have ever been told that we should be able
to say that.
The antidote to, the antidote, I've just done
that so doubt and surrender.
The next one is blame.
When change happens there is always one person
that we blame.
And it could be your boss and it could be
your colleague and it could be your child
and it could be your spouse and it could be
yourself, but there's always someone that
takes the blame, because it's really hard
to get into self responsibility when you're
in the middle of change.
How could this possibly be my thing?
What do you mean, like I'm responsible for
this thing that happened to me?
I can guarantee you, if you wanna get through
a life change, the quicker you go into self
responsibility, it doesn't mean other people
don't have their share of self responsibility,
but if there's one overarching theme, this
deep looking, this self responsibility, if
you want to get through change quicker, that's
what you need to go to.
So the antidote to blame is always self responsibility.
There's something in there for you and it's
gonna be a beautiful lesson when you give
it and once the ego kind of takes a little
bit of a break.
And the next change demon is impatience.
When we go through change time wrecks havoc
with us.
The change seems to last forever.
Time, you know, seems to not be moving.
You want to speed it up.
You do, you make bad decisions to speed up
the change.
You send e-mails way too quickly to send speed
up the change because the uncomfortableness
of staying in the middle of the change is
not something we want to be in.
Sometimes just waiting five minutes will actually
have some different things show up in the
change puzzle, whatever it is.
But we're very impulsive, so we're very impatient.
We're not willing to see what's in the gap.
We're not willing to see what new people are
gonna walk into our life, what new opportunities,
what new ideas are gonna show up.
But allowing yourself to be in that sort of
zone.
The antidote to impatience, believe it or
not, is not patience.
The antidote to impatience is endurance.
It's actually just having the courage to keep
going.
The sort of determination will always get
you through.
Having the courage to keep going.
It's not this sort of like, oh like I'm gonna
be super patient with life here.
No, do what you need to do, what's on your
plate.
The next two change demons.
One, the, one of them is guilt.
And this applies a lot more to women than
men.
Somehow men tend to not have the guilt gene.
But guilt is women's middle name for some
reason.
You feel guilty that you were fired.
You feel guilty that you messed up the presentation.
You feel guilty that you're sick.
You feel guilty that you're overweight.
You feel guilty that you can't stop smoking.
You feel guilty that your child isn't doing
well at school.
Whatever it is.
But somehow there's this sense of like, it's
my fault, which is very different than self
responsibility.
Self responsibility is this is my piece and
this is your piece.
It's not it's now all on me and by the way
you're gonna take the last 10, 20, 30 years
of your life and still kind of hold it with
you.
The antidote to guilt is always forgiveness.
It goes back to this, people are gonna change,
they're human.
You need to let it go.
It's this sense of the more I'm carrying from
the past, the less change is now available
for me coming forward in the future.
But this, this sense of what do I need to
let go of?
We all have our list what do we need to let
go of.
Who do I need to forgive?
It's such a big question.
What in me do I need to forgive?
Huge question.
We don't really want to go there.
We're sort of like busy and doing and we don't
kind of want to see that that's one of the
things that's really kind of holding us back.
And the last one is very closely related,
which is shame.
When people go through change, this level
of shame comes through them.
And it's very basic and it's very core emotion
and people don't talk about it very much.
But we feel ashamed that we don't have as
much money as we'd like.
Or that we aren't in the best of health.
Or that we aren't the greatest parent.
But there's this level of shame that no one
really wants to look at.
Or we're ashamed that we had breast cancer
or prostate cancer or that you know we're
not as effective as we thought we should.
The antidote to shame is always honor.
It's sort of stepping into that place and
go I am the person that got fired.
I'm the person that is sick.
But just owning it in a place of being powerful
about it actually moves you through the change.
The ignoring of it, the hoping no one ever
sees it and no one ever addresses it actually
just keeps the change constantly running the
show in the background.
So that's change demons.
I could say a lot more, but I'm gonna have
to move on.
Principle number five is what I call the principle
of acceptance.
So people who are good at change have no resistance
to the actual change that's going on.
When if you're in the midst of a change, the
thing that's making the change painful is
the amount of saying no to the change.
Any change.
Small change.
Big change.
The level of pushing the change away is what
makes the change so difficult.
So if you're, if you're in a work change and
something's happening, the quicker you can
get to I accept this change, which is very
different than I like this change, right?
I'm not saying you need to like the change.
But being able to step in and kind of go,
I accept it, allows you to be able to move
forward.
This is another favorite quote of mine is
by a woman called Byron Katie and she said
you know when you when you argue with reality
you lose, but only 100% of the time.
And we argue with reality every single day
in so many ways.
We argue with reality with people.
We constantly want people to be different.
Have you noticed that?
Constantly.
We're waiting for someone else to change.
You're waiting for your mother to change.
You're waiting for your parents to change.
You're waiting for your colleagues or your
boss to change.
There's this constant arguing with reality
of who you know people to be.
No more.
There's an arguing of reality of what's going
on in the external environment.
Do you know the energy it takes to argue with
reality all the time?
It's like being in a flowing river, where
you know life is taking you exactly on the
journey you're supposed to be on.
And when you, when life changes, or when you
know reality drops in, you do one of two things.
You're in the flowing river, you hang on to
the first rock or boulder, right?
I'm not gonna go forward.
I don't like what this relationship's now
gonna look at.
I don't like what this work is now gonna possibly
be.
So you're kind of holding, you're resisting
where life is actually already gonna take
you.
Or you might be in another category.
You start rowing back upstream.
I want the body back.
I want the relationship back.
I want the money back that I lost in the stock
market.
So there's a sense of like going backwards.
But when you're not in a place of sort of
I'm accepting the way it is, you're either
stuck in the paralysis or you're living in
the past.
It's one of those two things.
But it's never you know it's not the actual
change that's hard, again it's the energy
that you had invested in, my life is gonna
look/be a certain way.
So you know I always ask the question, what
is the one change or the one thing in your
life that you still have not accepted?
Because that also has tremendous power over
you.
You know is it something someone said?
Is it something someone did?
What's that one thing that you really need
to accept?
Something about yourself?
Something you still feel you know, I should
be different.
We all, we have such a should program on us.
We have a should program.
We have a comparison program.
We have a competition program on us.
We're, we're covered in programs.
And one of those programs is basically holding
you very hostage of you not being able to
move forward when a change happens.
[sound of drinking water]
Just so you know, the three most dominant
programs you have as human beings, this comes
from years of research, are three things.
The first one is love and approval.
The second one is control.
And the third one is safety.
Everything you do is to meet one of these
three programs.
Why you work here.
Who you're married to or why you're single.
Why you eat or take care of your health the
way you do is to meet one of these three programs.
You, you can see it in your colleagues and
your friends.
What is their dominant program?
Are they love and approval seekers?
Are they control people or I call them freaks?
Are they safety people?
Safe.
Right?
Everything needs to be safe.
If you can just see what is the dominant program
even in the people you work with and the people
you live with, you can meet them much more
at what is their dominant program.
They're wired this way.
And the thing you need to remember is once
you know what your own program is, most people,
for example if they are in love and approval,
they will do anything to get love and approval.
And the paradox with life is, the more you
move towards it, the more it moves away.
So the more I want love and approval, the
more it walks out the door.
The more I don't really need love and approval,
the more life kind of gives you it in bucket
loads.
The more you try and control life, you try
and control people, your environment, the
project, the work, the more control moves
away from you.
So being aware of what is your dominant program.
Because when life changes, it hits one of
these three programs.
Either love and approval's been chopped by
someone or something, your control's gone
out the door and you don't feel safe, but
one of them is most obvious.
And being able to rest in and remember, the
more I try and get safe, the more I'm gonna
feel unsafe.
That's all just on that particular point,
just remember.
And start noticing in other people, oh that
behavior is really about you know control
or it's really about safety, leading me right
into the next one.
Principle number six are the things you can
control when you're going through a life change.
So when things change everything feels very
out of control.
And as I said earlier, we do one thing.
We try and sort of change things on the outside.
The only thing you can control is your inner
world.
What do I mean by that specifically?
Your language and words.
The questions you ask yourself.
The stories you tell yourself and other people.
That's what I got from the people that I interviewed.
So I'll give you an example.
I interviewed people who had lost their jobs.
The language that they used.
The words that they used.
Of people that got through the change and
people who didn't.
People who are good at change do not use words
like disaster, nightmare, worst day ever,
crazy, horrific week.
They don't have that language.
They have a very different vocabulary.
So one of the things I'd invite you to look
at, whether you're going through a change
or you're not at this point, are what are
your go-to words?
Like where are you sloppy with your words?
Where are you sort of just quite casual about
throwing out very negatively charged emotional
words?
In work, in your personal environment, towards
yourself.
Because again, having the awareness of and
if you don't I can guarantee your friends
and colleagues can tell you because you use
these words all the time, you're not even
aware of them.
But where, where's just be very, have a finesse
about what the words are.
People who are good at change use words like
opportunity, lesson, this is a challenge,
you know I'm really being asked to step up
and look at something differently, but they
don't have this negative tirade of words.
Same thing with questions.
You know if you ask your mind a question,
it's gonna answer it.
So if you go why did this happen to me?
Why am I so unlucky?
Why is this guy such a jerk?
Why is this a woman such a whatever?
Your mind's gonna answer that and you're gonna
kind of feel ok well that must be the truth
because my mind answered it.
People who are good at change have a very
different level of questions.
How can this be a good thing?
How can I find some humor in this, this is
so crazy?
Who can help me?
Great question to ask yourself when you're
going through a change, which is not your
typical normal question.
You do have control over the questions that
you keep asking yourself.
And the final thing you can control, which
is so powerful, are the stories you tell yourself.
We are a walking library of stories.
You have a story about yourself, your weight
or why you can't lose it, how you are at work,
about men, about women, about your parents,
about why they're together, about why they
got divorced, about religion, about, you have
a story about everything.
You actually are a walking library of stories.
Your stories are not the facts.
Your stories are a story about what happened.
But there's again an addiction to sort of
holding on to here is the library of my life
and no one's gonna touch it.
If you want a new story of any kind.
If you want a new change.
If you want a, if you're going through a change
and you want to look at it differently, you
need to take one of these stories and actually
create some space in your library for a new
story, not hold the story.
If you don't know what your stories are, again
I guarantee you, just ask your friends or
people you work with.
You have a story about why you're single.
You have a story about why you can't lose
weight.
And I promise you, your friends are bored
with your story.
And I know this from very personal experience.
I used to have stories about being single.
Men in New York.
My parents.
Like I was a walking library of stories.
Until some pretty good friends kind of go,
you know what?
I'm really bored with the story about men
in New York.
And so you know what?
I had a choice.
I could fight the friend, who she was happily
married, of course, right?
I could fight the friend or I could actually
take it on and kind of go you know what, you're
right.
I have a really big story about that particular
issue.
And it's funny and I bring it up, but I promise
you, you have a story that you are also holding
onto for dear life because you think it's
the truth.
It's not the truth.
It's your story about it.
So when you're going through change, you know
there's a sense of again controlling the outside.
Turn it in.
You control yourself, watch how quickly your
external environment changes.
It's fascinating.
It's not anything we've been told.
We're told that you know, you move around
things on the outside and then you get to
feel better.
No, no, no, no, no.
You get to feel better and the outside tends
to sort of shift around.
Put it to the test.
I'm just, I'm inviting you to actually look
at the effect of that.
Principle number seven.
Principle number seven is what I call your
spiritual side.
Every person I interviewed going through change
that had found their courage and had found
their strength and had found their inspiration
referred to something to do with their spirituality
or religion.
They definitely didn't all agree on what they
called it.
Some called it grace, some called it presence,
some called it God, some called it Buddha,
some called it life, the universe, but they
all agreed in one thing.
Something bigger is going on here.
I don't know why I'm in this change.
It's crazy.
It's difficult.
It's amazing.
I'm overwhelmed.
Whatever it is, you know?
We all have sort of the, the, the change is
a particular way story going on.
But they had a sense of, I don't know what
it is but I feel like something bigger is
happening here.
And so trusting in the, the something bigger,
whatever that is for you.
But change is always an invitation to sort
of get connected with that part which very
often when life is all rosy and happy, we
tend to forget about that part.
We tend to step into it as an invitation where,
oh I actually need to connect a little bit
more with that.
Again you name it what you want.
One of the number one ways I would suggest
people to do it is just to find stillness.
Find silence of any kind at any time.
Five minutes, ten minutes, twenty minutes.
And I can tell you, if you do not have 20
minutes in your day to be still, there's something
wrong with your day.
There's gotta, you've gotta find it, ten,
fifteen minutes of just stillness.
No distractions.
No busyness.
Because if you can't, I would invite you to
sort of say, well what is it that you don't
wanna hear?
What is it that you don't wanna listen?
Why, why is silence so scary?
Like I, I make it what I call a non-negotiable
and I would invite you all to look at your
non-negotiables and pick a couple.
What are the things that you don't negotiate
for anything?
Not your kids, not your boss, not your parents,
not anyone?
What are you non-negotiables?
My non-negotiables are my spiritual path and
my health.
No one touches those.
And guess what?
When you create a bit of a sacred space around
whatever those non-negotiables are, life tends
to keep you away from them, it's fine, because
you've actually taken a stand for them.
But find that you know when everything in
your life is changing, you have to find something
that doesn't change.
You have to.
And a lot of the times when you're going through
one change, life does a really funny thing.
It brings two or three more changes with it.
Right?
It's natural.
Your job changes and now your relationships
also change.
Your money's changing and now you know your
home something is changing as well.
So life tends to bring with it more than one
change at a time.
It's my number one thing I would say, when
you're in a change, you need to find a place
that is what I call the silent witness.
The silent observer that can kind of see but
not be part of the change.
And the it the biggest way to get in touch
with that is to meditate.
And if meditation's a scary word, it's just
to sit in silence and just to sort of watch,
watch your thoughts.
You don't even need to get involved.
You don't need to entertain them, but there's
a real invitation to do, you know, if it's
not meditation, go into nature.
If it's not nature, start journaling.
But there's plenty of ways to sort of get
in touch with that more spiritual core.
Ok.
Principle number eight.
So much more I could have said on spirituality,
but-- Principle number eight is what I call
your change support team.
People who are good at change are not alone.
I'd say it's our biggest flaw as human beings.
We keep thinking we're alone.
I'm the only one going through this change.
No one has ever felt this bad.
No one has ever eaten this much ice cream.
No one has ever cried so much on the couch.
No one has ever been so heart broken for so
long.
Like, we, we do this all the time.
No one has ever messed up as much as I have.
No one has ever, you know, it's like the list
continues.
But we have the sense that we're alone.
I'm the only one.
And what does that do?
That separates us once again from life.
It separates us from people.
It separates us from people who could be helping.
So just ask yourself, are you, are you a bit
of a I'm alone person?
Because if you are you're gonna make your
life really difficult because life is a combination
of changes.
Here's what's interesting.
When you do go through change, your change
support team are not necessarily the people
you would naturally go to.
You know, when you go through change I don't
necessarily recommend calling your mother.
Not a good idea.
She loves you, she's on your love team, but
she's not necessarily on your change team.
She's gonna be worried and she's gonna ask
you a million questions and five days later
when you're kind of better, she's still worrying
about your change.
So when you're going through a change, be
very mindful of who you're gonna call.
Who actually can help you?
Who's on your change team?
They're not your closest friends, partners,
husbands, wives.
They are gonna be quite shaken by your change.
The most beautiful thing is when you go through
change new people tend to show up in your
life who have no idea who you are.
They don't have this fixed identity of you
know Mike is this or Ann is that.
There's sort of a freedom about who and what
you are.
They don't know how many times you've tried
to lose weight or how many tries you've tried
to stop smoking or how many times you've messed
up doing a particular thing.
There's a neutrality about them.
But be very careful, you know I always say
look at the five people that you spend the
most amount of time with.
Five people you spend the most amount of time
with have a massive influence on your life.
Massive.
In every regard.
Who are your five people?
Because we're very casual about who influences
us when we're going through change.
And you don't get good advice.
You get their beliefs and their opinions and
their fears and their conditioning.
That's not advice.
That's their stuff that they need to go work
through.
There's two types of people that I would say
you, you find when you go through change.
People that get in the hole with you, right?
You're in the hole, they go in the hole with
you.
He's such a jerk.
Absolutely she should never have done that.
I can't believe he did that to you.
Right?
There's people that agree with you.
And they kind of casually somewhat make you
feel better for about half a second.
And they're very often the people that drag
you for a drink.
Let's drink it away or let's eat it away.
Because they actually don't know quite how
to deal with it, right?
But they're not comfortable.
And some of you might be these kind of people,
which is sort of like, oooh my girl, my friend,
my partner's going through a change, I'm gonna
try and you know distract them in some way.
But some people walk right in the hole with
you and they don't, they're not very helpful.
So don't surround yourself with those people,
who all they do is agree with you.
You want people who are what I call ladder
people.
They see you in a hole, they hand you a ladder
and somehow they get you up the ladder.
And you resist those people because it's much
more comfortable being in the hole.
You get attention.
You get compassion.
You get, you know, validation.
But get people who are actually gonna walk
you up the ladder.
Those are the most important things.
So that's change support team.
Be, just be mindful of who's on your team,
you know, if you're thinking about making
a change, who has made that change before
you?
That would be a great person to go to.
Most people if they've been through a cancer
diagnosis, they want to help.
If someone has started a business, they want
to help.
If someone's lost weight, they want to help.
Who needs to be on your change team?
Always a very powerful question to ask.
The final principle of change is what I call
the action principle.
And there's a reason why this principle is
at the end of the book as opposed to right
at the beginning.
Because if you haven't figured it out by now,
all change is emotional.
Change is not about taking actions.
The actions to get divorced are actually very
easy.
The actions to quit smoking are really easy.
The actions to lose weight are very easy.
The actions to you know start a business are
pretty easy.
It's the emotions that get in the way.
It's all the things we've been talking about
up 'til now.
With that said I would say no change happens
without some action.
Once the emotions are in a place where you're
mindful about them, you actually need to get
on the court.
You can't just be on the stands talking about
the change all the time.
You need to get on the court.
So whatever change is happening ask yourself,
have I actually picked up a racket or do I
just keep on talking about it?
The most interesting part that I found in
the action principle with people that I interviewed
was this.
The most important action people took when
they go through change was to take care of
their health.
I mean that was incredibly interesting to
me because to me I thought, ok, they're gonna
be doing a particular thing.
No, no, no, no.
When you're going through change, health is
the number one thing that walks out the door.
You sleep less, or you sleep more.
You start drinking a lot more coffee, alcohol.
You've no time for exercise, 'cause now this
change has happened and it's like, I have
no time.
And usually you're eating a lot worse, comfort,
comfort, just to fill up the uncertainty because
there's so much.
So the number one thing that walks out the
door is your health.
So I'd interview people and I'd be like, ok,
what really helped you?
And they said one thing.
He goes I took care of myself.
That's it.
So again sounds very simple, but the more
you take care of yourself the higher your
self esteem is, the more you start you know
even just exercise.
I say to a lot of people who come see me,
I've done a lot of one on one coaching.
They go I'm so depressed or I'm stuck or I'm
paralyzed.
They're not moving or they're dehydrated.
Of course they're depressed.
Nothing's moving through the body.
They haven't had a proper meal.
They haven't had some sleep.
So it's not necessarily the emotions are whacking
you, you're not actually doing things to take
care of it, so I, I came up with just a very
simple acronym, it's what I call the seed
of change, S-E-E-D.
This is as basic as it gets and most of you,
none of us are doing this.
S is for sleep.
E is for exercise.
E is for eating well.
And D is for drinking water.
Just those things will have a massive influence
on how you go through change.
The actions of change, my final point, actions
of change are small actions.
People who go through change do not jump to
the top of the mountain as a metaphor for
the film that's coming.
It's a step at a time.
It's like a woodpecker.
What is the action?
What's the one thing I've got to do now?
What can I do today?
What can I do tomorrow?
Who can help me with this action tomorrow?
But what are you actually doing because you
never know when that tree's gonna fall.
But the actions of actually getting sort of
in the flow, that's where, where things really
start happening.
So again a lot more stuff to say about action,
but are you in action or are you actually
in inaction?
So those are the nine principles.
Again what I would say is just you know look
at them as a global, your beliefs, the change
guarantee, the change muscle, the change demons,
your emotions that get in the way, the power
of acceptance.
Are you an accepting person when it comes
to change?
The things you can control.
Are you an external control person or more
of an inwardly focused person?
Your spiritual side, you know, is that something
that has gotten your attention lately or not?
Because a change is always an invitation to
look at the inner world, not the outer world.
Your change team, who's on it?
And taking action.
So with that I'm just gonna wrap up and just
give you a sense you know the last couple
of years I did take time off from the writing
and I did take time off from the speaking
and I decided to just focus on what my next
book is gonna be, so I'll give you a sneak
one minute about what that is.
I'm writing a book called A Foot In Both Worlds.
And A Foot In Both Worlds is about walking
a spiritual path or a mindful path or a conscious
path, whatever you want to call it and fully
being in the world.
So it's not an either/or, which a lot of the
times people kind of go, well it's either
gonna be this or it's gonna be that.
Either I'm gonna be spiritual or I'm gonna
make a lot of money.
Either I'm gonna be in a relationship having
sex or I'm gonna be meditating every day on
a cushion.
Like people have funny ideas about the either/or
of this concept, so I wanted to see both for
myself how it was possible to live in New
York City in a fully mindful way, in a fully
conscious way, in a relationship, eating well,
you know in, in doing work that mattered,
making money, whatever it was.
And interviewing people who really do have
a foot in both worlds.
And then as Rachel said as well I wanted to
just get on you know more of the app bandwidth
and sort of turn this into an iPhone app.
So Mindful365 we're testing it right now and
it'll be out probably in September and we're
hoping to do an android version soon, believe
me.
And what we've also done is we're doing it
as a daily e-mail for people who don't have
smart phones.
But it's just a paragraph or two of the similar
type of content I've been speaking about,
looking at 20 years of research in personal
development in life skills, where we'll send
you a question to focus on for the day and
you know and it could be about looking at
your disapproval or looking at how impatient
you are today or looking at, you know, your
relationship to your body in a particular
way.
But I invite you all to look at that, it's
gonna be at Mindful365.com and then on obviously
on the iTunes store as well.
And then the film is this afternoon.
I don't know if you guys have the time to
come, but that was an extraordinary, extraordinary
experience.
But I want to take some questions if you guys
have any.
Thank you very much.
[audience applause]
>>Male #2: So you talk about people being,
people being positive.
Have you encountered the other end of the
spectrum?
Naivete, you know, this is gonna work in some
really unrealistic way as being another way
that people
>>Ariane: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>>Male #2: fail at making change?
>>Ariane: Did everyone hear that?
So he was saying one of the things I noticed
is when people are positive, no matter what,
somehow they find a way through change.
And his question was, have you found the other
side of the spectrum, is people who have a
degree of naivete and actually don't know
somehow things work out?
There is something very positive in actually
not knowing and not knowing and not having
a plan and not having any idea how to go through
it, but actually also pulls you through.
One of the, the hardest things to get through
when you're going through change is the sense
of I know.
Is the sense of I'm educated, I was told,
I've been through this before, other people
have told me and so there there's a there's
a clinging to a particular way of having it
being.
But I'll give you an example.
I've never built an app before, and I think
there's an advantage of being a bit naive
about not having built an app so I'm not trying
to be the perfect app builder, right?
I'm just going ahead and giving what I can
and doing the content I can and figuring it
out along the way.
And I'm being quite positive about it.
Where I just know that it's gonna be helpful,
it's gonna make a difference.
That's the part very often that pulls you
through.
I think when you go through change, I didn't
mention this, but when you go through change
one of the big differences is, if you know
why you are going through the change, if you
know why you are making the change, the why
is the fuel that pulls you through.
Me trying to figure out app developers and
coding and everything is not what pulls me
through.
The why of wanting to make a difference, right?
The why of knowing that it's gonna be helpful
for people who are gonna find this, that's
what makes the difference.
So you can be very naive about a change that
you're in, but if you know why you're going
through it, that's usually the thing that
pulls you through.
So the question was any tips on helping an
introvert going through change?
The number one thing I would say is, is stop
labeling yourself and stop labeling anyone
who is a particular way.
Because the labeling has basically put a box
over how you should be, how you should act,
how much you should talk, how you should interact
with others, so whether you are or you're
not, I'm not arguing with the reality of the
thing.
I'm arguing with the label of the thing, which
stops you from naturally doing what it is
that the expression might come through.
Beyond the labeling, and I would invite you
know most people to stop labeling anyone in
any way, I would say, get in touch with the
intuition, you know.
We all have that inner microphone.
We all, you don't need to be extroverted or
introverted, it goes off really loudly at
particular times.
And what we do is we're experts at turning
the microphone down.
But the good thing about life is, life never
lets you turn it off.
It's never at a zero.
It's kind of at this latent, you can kind
of always hear it and you're always trying
to make it quieter.
But as an introvert, extrovert, I would say
turn the inner microphone on, give it a voice
and sort of listen to what it's saying about
a particular area of your life, about something
that's going on for you personally, professionally,
financially.
You know, I'd say turning on, turning on the
intuition.
And for people you know I often get the flip
question, which is, well, well, I don't even
know what my intuition is.
Which is a great question, 'cause a lot of
people it's like, there's intuition and then
there's also your conditioning, right?
There's like my conditioning is telling me
definitely don't do this.
No, no, no.
That's not your intuition.
If you're confused about the two, here's where
you go.
You always go to your body.
Your body never lies.
Are you feeling tight?
Are you not sleeping?
Are you nervous?
Are you sweating?
Are you eating or drinking more than usual?
If you're about to do a deal, are you really
contracted?
So for people who, you know the mind is busy,
or whatever is going on, you always go to
the body.
How is the body feeling?
If you're invited to do something, what does
the heart want?
Do I get a yes or do I get a no?
And we ignore it all the time and so life
throws another change at us, and another change,
and another change until we actually start
listening to what's the inner intuition?
What's the microphone actually wanting to
have you say yes to?
And it's hard sometimes because you've gotta
say no to things that people want you to say
yes to.
And you've gotta say no to things that you've
always been expected to do, right?
And so there's a sense of like wanting to
please when you're going through change and
yet also wanting to honor what's going on
inside.
So I'd say always turning on the heart.
Turning on the intuition.
Listening more.
Getting away from the noise and the busyness
of other people who are trying to, trying
to influence you.
I wouldn't say it was people who didn't make
it through change, it's people who struggled
a lot through change.
So when they were going through change, instead
of actually moving you know at the pace that
they would have maybe liked to move, they
were stuck for the change for years and years
and years.
So I interviewed people who'd lost a loved
one and I could tell people who had, who had
made it something beautiful and they had started
a foundation or they had done something positive
or they had started celebrating that person's
passing as opposed to doing it in a very different
sort of way.
So life, you're gonna make it no matter what.
That's a done deal.
Life's gonna take care of every single one
of us.
It's just a matter of how much suffering are
you gonna take on when life gives you a change
to look at?
I wanted to see well why is it some people
have an easier time through change?
Why are they less stressed?
Why are they less sad?
Why are they more excited?
Because you know one of the things we didn't
talk about is good changes are actually just
as hard as the difficult changes, you know.
People getting married.
People having children.
People getting promoted.
People who've you know gone on and started
businesses, been very successful.
The good changes bring up a lot of these same
issues, because something's changed.
Right?
It's just not what they thought and they don't
quite know how to deal with it.
So it's not only the difficult challenging
ones.
When I interviewed people, I interviewed people
who had gone through the greatest things,
winning the lottery, I interviewed a few of
those people, and just how difficult it was
for them to be with a positive change as well.
So it wasn't make it or not make it and I
apologize if I said that.
It was more, it was more the ease with which
they transitioned through change.
Good question.
So is it possible to help someone through
a change if they're not really willing to
accept what's going on?
I would say yes and the best way to help someone
through change is to be a refuge for them.
And by refuge I mean they can stay in whatever
feeling they're at, place they're at, it doesn't
make you feel uncomfortable.
You basically allow them to be, because what
they need is love and what they need is acceptance.
They don't need tips, they don't need advice.
If they ask for guidance, you give it, if
not you're encroaching, right?
And I've, I'm, I've been guilty of that too
as someone who likes to help people through
change it's very easy to want to change.
But the one place to go to is just go, what
does this person most need?
That's the question.
Does this person need, you know, some affection?
Does this person need me to check in with
them?
Does this person need a referral to someone?
But it's not what you think they need, it's
really tuning in and counting on what does
this person need.
But it's, it's a radical acceptance of who
they are and it's also a seeing of who they're
gonna be on the other end of this.
So if you can already hold a vision for how
they're gonna be when they get through this,
they start feeling that when they're around
you.
They don't feel stuck around you.
You've already seen them move through the
challenge.
You've already seen them healthy.
You've already seen them in a relationship
or whatever it is that they're looking to
be in.
Thank you very much.
[audience applause]